the FBI opens an investigation into
President Trump as a Russian agent the
government shutdown continues and
Democrats move even further to the left
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
welcome to a brand-new week I know
you're excited to be here I'm excited to
be here it's gonna be a long week we
will be here with you all week long at
the end of the week by the way we are
going to the March for Life having to be
speaking at the March for Life we're
doing my podcast live from the March for
Life so if you're in the DC area or if
you're coming for the March for Life
than I expect to see you there I mean
we're braving the cold to bring you this
show you should the least you could do
is to be there with us and then we can
all suffer together through the
blistering cold of Washington DC I'm
from LA so anything below 70 degrees is
super cold okay we'll get to all the
actual news of the day in just one
second first we need to talk about your
screen time now I know you spend an
awful lot of time with grins and frankly
we're grateful here at the Daily wire
because that means you're probably
engaging without content but you know
how you have those headaches you know
your eyes kind of hurt well the reason
for that is because when you spend that
much time in front of a screen
you're probably hurting your eyes a
little bit you can protect your eyes
with a pair of Felix grey glasses that
are available with or without
prescription felix great glasses are a
lifesaver for me because they filter out
90% of high-energy blue light they
eliminate the glare coming off of all
those screens so I can live my life
without tired dry eyes or blurry vision
or headaches
unlike other blue light filter and
glasses Felix Gray's have no yellow lens
tint so you can see everything in its
true color and Felix gray frames are
handcrafted from high-quality materials
like organic Italian acetate premium
German steel in fact throwing on some
Felix grazes in an easy way to look
pretty put together if I want to look
smart like the people on MSNBC I just
throw on my Felix grays and I'm good to
go go check out the Felix gray glasses
right now by going to Felix gray glasses
dot-com slash pens protect your eyes
today that is Felix gray glasses comm
slash man again protect your eyes you
don't necessarily have I don't wear
glasses normally but I wear if you look
to praise when I'm trying to make my
eyes feel better go check them out Felix
gray glasses dot-com slash man they're
also available with prescription
strength as well Felix great glasses
calm slash man okay so the big story
over the weekend is that the FBI was
apparently investigating president Trump
as in like investigating him during the
campaign in 2016 and 2017 in 2017 they
opened an investigation into president
Trump concerned that he might be a
Russian agent and now this is ridiculous
okay he's on the face of it it is
ridiculous the idea that the President
of the United States was a Manchurian
Candidate that somehow he was being
blackmailed by
with compromise by Vladimir Putin that
all of the activities during the
campaign weren't just trump not knowing
what he's doing or being incompetent
that we had to chalk it all up to
President Trump was in a back room with
Vladimir Putin and they were putting
together their master plan for taking
over the universe and then he was going
to be triggered by some sort of
watchword from Vladimir Putin or
something all this is asinine
here's what the New York Times reported
however in the days after President
Trump fired James be Comey as FBI
director law enforcement officials
became so concerned by the president's
behavior that they began investigating
whether he had been working on behalf of
Russia against American interests
according to former law enforcement
officials and others familiar with the
investigation hey this is a wild
overreach by the FBI and it gives a lot
of a lot of credence to the Trump
administration and Trump allied claimed
that the FBI and the so-called deep
State were out to get president Trump
why because what triggered this was not
all of the knowledge during the campaign
what triggered this was not all of the
contacts between Trump campaign
officials and Russian officials or the
Trump Tower meeting of June 2016 know
what triggered this was Trump firing
James Comey so what this sounds more
like is the president fires the head of
the FBI who was an incompetent boob and
then all of the people left over at the
FBI say well you know what I'll bet the
president fired him because he's a
Russian agent now James Comey himself
testified openly before Congress that
Trump did not attempt to shut down the
Muller investigation or hamper the
Muller investigation in the wake of
James commis firing or before James
Comey is firing in fact he was just
irritated that Comey wouldn't issue a
statement saying that Trump was not
under investigation that's all that
happened right Trump said that openly he
said the reason that I fired James Comey
is because I asked Comey for a
declaration that I was not personally
under investigation and Comey said he
wouldn't do it and so I fired him they
said that it would take pressure off him
with regards to Russia people
interpreted that is that it was as
though Comey was on the verge of nailing
Trump on his Russian relationships when
in reality what Trump was saying was I
want Co me out because Comey won't just
leave me alone about the rush of stuff
and I didn't do anything so why would he
just leave me alone and the FBI in the
aftermath of Kobe's firing which Trump
had every legal ability to do every
president can fire every head of the FBI
the executive branch is a unitary branch
it's so funny folks on the left like to
rip on the
theory of the unitary executive but the
Constitution is very clear about this
the head of the FBI works for the
President of the United States executive
branch agencies are answerable to the
President of the United States
if Trump wanted to fire commie he had
every right capacity and constitutional
ability to do so and yet after Comey was
fired the FBI tried to open an
investigation into whether Trump was a
Russian agent again in a second into all
of the defensive claims by the FBI and
its advocates on why they opened this
investigation according to the New York
Times the inquiry carried explosive
implications counterintelligence
investigators had to consider whether
the president's own actions constituted
a possible threat to national security
agents also sought to determine whether
mr. Trump was knowingly working for
Russia or had unwittingly fallen under
Moscow's influence again this is
inappropriate stuff if you don't
actually have evidence that the
president is being blackmailed if you
don't have evidence that the president
is in fact a Russian agents then
evaluating his policies with an eye
toward whether he is a Russian agent is
just an executive branch agency
second-guessing the policies of the
president can you imagine if the FBI had
opened up an investigation against
Barack Obama in 2013 on his Syria policy
remember in 2012 Barack Obama openly on
a mic that everyone heard said to
Medvedev who was then the prime minister
or the president of Russia he said to
him at that time if you get your boss to
leave me alone then I'll have more
flexibility in dealing with Russia once
I am reelected and then guess what
happened the Russians went into Crimea
and Obama did nothing
the Russians went into Syria and Obama
handed over control of the Syrian the
Syrian situation to the Russians did the
FBI open an investigation and say hey
wait a second you know Obama he had this
promise that he made to the Russians
about the election and then he was real
soft on the Russians after the election
maybe he's maybe the Russian agent can
you imagine if they'd open that
investigation everybody would have said
rightly so that the FBI has no right and
no capacity to go after a president
based on public policy simply because
they don't like the public policy that
the president is pursuing this is a
massive FBI overreach and this is coming
from somebody who has said we should
wait for the results of the Muller
investigation I've said all along let's
investigation let's wait for all the
facts to come out I don't believe in
rushon collusion theory I think that
it's hogwash as far as the evidence that
I can see so far but I can see why
people would have been suspicious of
Carter page I can see why people would
have been suspicious of various other
members of the Trump campaign I can see
why their actions Papadopoulos I can see
why those actions would have looked
suspicious to be ligands who had the
Trump Tower meeting looked suspicious to
people but that does not mean that the
FBI opening an investigation into the
President of the United States and
suggesting that the President of the
United States is in fact a Russian plant
that that's justified constitutionally
or otherwise and opening it under the
counterintelligence rubric by the way is
really kind of gross Andy McCarthy
points this out today in a piece over at
Fox News he's been saying for a long
time that the FBI was using the rubric
of counterintelligence in order to
target President Trump the case he's
basically been making is there are two
types of Investigations that the FBI
does one is counterintelligence which is
them trying to fight off Russian
influence and then there's Criminal
Investigation them trying to investigate
criminal activity on American soil these
are not the same thing the standard of
proof for counterintelligence is not the
same as the standard of proof for a
criminal investigation if they actually
wanted to bring some sort of criminal
prosecution against someone you have to
reach a certain level of proof
counterintelligence is not designed to
do that counterintelligence is just
designed for you to go and see the facts
and then fight those facts on the ground
as they exist usually abroad when
McCarthy has been saying for a long time
is the FBI was going after Trump with
counterintelligence so that they didn't
have to reach the level of proof
necessitated by a criminal investigation
McCarthy writes this today former
federal prosecutor he says because the
FBI did not have solid evidence of a
crime they did it under
counterintelligence Authority rather
than criminal authority calculating that
the cover of probing Russia's
interference in the 2016 election would
enable them to keep investigating while
they tried to tighten up the obstruction
case or find some other criminal defense
in other words the counterintelligence
aspect here was just a cover for them to
go after Trump personally McCarthy says
the investigation was always hoping to
find something on Trump that is why for
example when director Comey briefed then
president-elect Trump about the steel
dossier he told from only about the
salacious allegation involving
prostitutes in a Moscow hotel he did not
tell the president-elect either that the
main thrust of the dossier was Trump's
purported
leonov's conspiracy with the kremlin nor
that the FBI had gone to the FISA Court
to get surveillance warrants based on
the dossier the FBI was telling the
president-elect that the allegations
were salacious and unverified and at
that very moment they were presenting
them to a federal court as information
the judges could rely on to authorize
spying so this is pretty dirty stuff
then the New York Times report continues
it says the investigation the FBI opened
into mr. Trump also had a criminal
aspect which had long been publicly
known whether his firing of mr. Comey
constituted obstruction of justice now
again it did not it did not constitute
obstruction of justice I've gone through
the statutes on the program before it is
not obstruction of justice for the
President of the United States to fire
his own FBI director okay that's not how
this works there are actual statutes
with regard to obstruction of justice
there are several statutes with regard
to obstruction of justice
there's 18 USC 1503 this is the
so-called omnibus clause under American
law
it covers corruptly or by any
threatening letter or communication
influencing or impeding or endeavoring
to influence in obstruct or impede the
to administration of justice but that
requires a pending judicial proceeding
in other words there's a trial going on
and you try to obstruct justice by
intimidating a witness there is no
pending judicial proceeding this statute
does not apply 18 USC 1512 C this
provision of law covers anyone who
obstructs influences or impedes an
official proceeding or attempts to do so
it is not clear that an FBI
investigation is in fact an official
proceeding and in order for you to
violate this clause in order for Trump
to violate this clause he would have had
to knowingly do so okay so it's not
enough just to fire somebody and that
firing ends up impeding something you
actually have to have intended to do so
they have no proof of that 18 USC 1519
this provision covers destroying
evidence related to a federal
investigation there is no allegation
even that Trump destroyed evidence and
when people talk about the FBI opening
an obstruction of justice investigation
into Trump over firing someone he has
plenary power to dispense with that's
nonsense
that's nonsense according to the New
York Times agents and senior FBI
officials had grown suspicious of mr.
Trump's ties to Russia during the 2016
campaign but held off on opening an
investigation into him the people said
in pep in part because they were
uncertain how to proceed with an inquiry
of such sensitivity and magnitude well
if you knew about all the stuff in 2016
the seven 2017
was not worse than the stuff in 2016
just objectively speaking all of the bad
stuff that happened basically happened
in 2016 by 2017 Trump had already fired
Michael Flynn by 2017 he fired James
Comey but that was not obstruction of
justice as I've explained so there's
really no case for opening an
investigation into Trump as Kremlin
agents in 2017 if you want to make that
case you make it about 2016 but they
didn't the president's activities before
and after mr. Comey is firing in May
2017 particularly two instances in which
Trump tied the Comey dismissal to the
Russia investigation help prompt the
counterintelligence aspect of the
inquiry according to people at the FBI
again if your boss gets fired you open
an investigation into his firing I'm
gonna say that that looks very
retaliatory it doesn't look like this is
power the FBI should have I'll get more
into this in just one second first let's
talk about how you actually frame your
picture so I have to tell you guys about
an amazing new service that I don't know
about it's called frame bridge frame
which makes it really easy and
affordable to custom frame your favorite
things from art prints and posters to
the photos sitting on your phone I have
tons of photos on my phone at my kids
particularly and theirs are sitting
there they're sitting there digitally
and I haven't bothered to go get frames
because frames are super expensive
they're really inconvenient frame bridge
makes all of this possible you can frame
much more inexpensively in much nicer
fashion custom framing go to frame
bridge comm you upload your photo or
they send you packaging to safely mail
in your physical pieces you can preview
your item online in any frame style you
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their design team
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you pay at a framing store their prices
start at 39 bucks all shipping is free
plus my listeners get 15% off their
first order at frame bridge comm when
they use my promo code Shapiro again
that is promo code Shapiro at frame
bridge comm I've been using frame bridge
for a while they are fantastic get
started today with just a few taps on
your phone go to frame bridge comm news
promo code Shapiro to save an additional
15% off your first order in fact I'm
using frame bridge right now my wife and
I vacationed in Hawaii we took a bunch
of pictures with the kids some of them
are great we hadn't really figured out
how to frame them yet so now we are
using frame bridge go to frame bridge
comm promo code Shapiro frame bridge
comm promo code Shapiro used that promo
code Shapiro and save an additional 15%
off your first order go check it out
right now okay so the
New York Times reports at the special
counsel Robert Muller took over the
inquiry into mr. Trump one who's
appointed days after FBI officials
opened it that inquiry is part of mr.
Miller's broader examination of how
Russian operatives interfered in the
2016 election and whether any Trump
associates conspired with them it is
unclear whether mr. Muller is still
pursuing the counterintelligence matter
and some former law enforcement
officials outside the investigation have
questioned whether agents overstepped in
opening it the answer of course is yeah
I mean it kind of looks like it what
they're basically claiming is that if
Trump fired call me to stop the Russia
investigation that would have been
obstruction but you may notice something
what's the calendar say today that's
right it's January 14th 2019 the Russia
investigation opened in 2016 it is now
been three years of investigating two
and a half years of investigating has it
stopped at any time no it's never
stopped so where exactly is the case for
obstruction of justice where exactly is
the case that Trump is in fact a Russian
agent Rudy Giuliani's the president's
lawyer he says the fact that it goes
back a year and a half and nothing came
of it that showed a breach of national
security means that they found nothing
Trump is rightly very upset about all of
this and he has a right to be if it
turns out that at the end of this long
chain of events the Moller investigation
comes up with basically nothing then
that is going to speak to whether this
investigation should have taken so long
whether this investigation was
appropriately launched in the first
place whether this investigation was in
fact a political project to get Trump
now two things can be true at once it
can be true that the investigation comes
up with nothing
and that it was launched in good faith
but it makes it hard to make that claim
when you got members of the FBI
apparently vindictively launching
investigations into whether Trump was a
Russian asset in 2017 when you do have
people inside the FBI like Peter struck
a motivated anti Trump guy leading the
investigation if we're not asking these
questions we are not doing our jobs now
the media are beginning to realize that
we some members of the media that the
Muller investigation may not end the way
they wanted to ABC News's Jonathan Karl
made a stunning admission yesterday on
this week on ABC News here's what he had
to say this is all building up to the
modern report and raising expectations
of a bombshell report and they've been
expectations that have been building of
course for over a year on this
but people who are closest to to what
mother has been doing of interacting
with the special council cautioned me
that this report is almost certain to be
anti-climatic that if you look at what
the FBI was investigating in that New
York Times report look at what they were
investigating Muller did not go anywhere
with that investigation okay so what is
this all gonna be the answer may come up
with nothing this that's been my
prediction for a long time is that we
come up with some nasty indicators that
members of from scheme were talking with
the Russians like Donald from jr. for
example or that members of Trump's team
were unwittingly working with Russians
who were connected to the Russian
government something like that the idea
that Trump was sitting behind the
curtain waving his wand and making the
magic happen I just don't think that
there's any evidence of that whatsoever
if that if that changes then I'll change
my opinion but based on the evidence so
far you got to be asking what exactly
prompted the FBI to open an
investigation for Trump as a Russian
agent the guy is one of the most
prominent people in American public life
for the last four decades what exactly
did they target him
back when he was on the cover of Playboy
in like 1990 back when he was doing the
apprentice in the mid 2000s when did the
Russians decide you know what let's get
behind the reality TV show star and make
him into a full-blown Russian agent
that's conspiracy theory nonsense if
that's what the FBI was investigating
Lindsey Graham senator from South
Carolina says as much he's exactly right
I'm gonna ask the FBI director was there
a counterintelligence investigation
opened up regarding the president as
being a potential agent of the Russians
I find it astonishing and to me it tells
me a lot about the people running the
FBI McCabe and that crowd I don't trust
him as far as I throw them so if this
really did happen Congress needs to know
about it and I and what I want to do is
make sure how could the FBI do that what
kind of checks and balances are there
now listen I want to believe in the
veracity of the FBI I know a lot of FBI
agents I think the vast majority of FBI
agents are wonderful folks who are doing
a really great job keeping Americans
safe I want to believe in our law
enforcement institutions well in the
leadership of those law enforcement
institutions are people like Peter
struck and Lisa Paige makes it kind of
hard and when they're making claims that
Trump was a Russian agent not just that
they were going to investigate Russian
ties and then see where those led but
instead that Trump was himself deeply in
come on I mean I'm gonna need some
evidence for that other than Trump has a
big mouth first of all if Trump were
really a Russian agent do you think he
could keep his mouth shut about it dude
can't keep his mouth shut about anything
Trump would be out there actually
speaking Russian if you're a Russian
agent right Trump would be out there
singing the Soviet national anthem like
the characters in The Hunt for Red
October I mean the president doesn't
he's not known for his capacity for
secrecy the president isn't exactly
known for his subtlety like if you're
going to pick a person to be a Russian
plant or a Russian spy really Donald
Trump real that that's where you were
gonna go with like Trump would go out
there in the middle of a campaign be
like you know who I love
911 admitting he's the real president
he's great he's gonna like when I'm
president I'm gonna talk to him every
day we're gonna read each other mash
notes it can be unbelievable babe I
think that's what it would have been hey
come on come on so the Democrats are
desperately trying to defend the FBI's
activity here Tim Kaine the senator from
Virginia he says well the FBI went after
Trump because they had good reason to do
so here's the excuse making from people
who say the FBI had a reason to consider
Trump a Russian plant gets less did the
FBI overreact I think the question is
this they had to have a very deep level
of concern about this president to take
this step and that's again why we need
to protect the Muller investigation and
I think that's going to be a critical
issue in the Judiciary Committee
hearings about the attorney general
nominee will you guarantee to protect
this investigation and will you make
sure that the American public and
Congress get the results of it so here
this really is the key question though
the real key question is the one that
Kane is mentioning here how deep does
the FBI's level of suspicion have to run
for them to launch an investigation if
they're talking about Trump is Russian
agent my suspicion is not all that deep
that they could just take Flyers on
investigations which does raise systemic
questions about the FBI not just about
the Trump investigation but what kind of
information is necessary for them to
actually open an investigation targeting
American citizens it makes you really
disquieted about the nature of American
power about law enforcement power Macy
ends a sort of a reasoned calm
libertarian looking at this sort of
stuff and going hold up the FBI can just
launch an investigation based on a
couple of people who don't like Trump
not like me
James Comey and then they can open a
full-on counterintelligence
investigation into the president that's
a thing again Democrats who five minutes
ago hated the FBI now love the FBI they
they love this stuff so mark Warner from
West Virginia
he says the FBI went after President
Trump for good reason also I think we're
seeing these independent actions even
independent of Muller which is the lead
up and some of the rationale about why
this investigation started and why so
many Americans like myself had been
concerned for so long there was a enough
concern that the Senate Intelligence
Committee in a bipartisan fashion the
House Intelligence Committee in a
slightly less bipartisan fashion
launched investigations our
investigation is almost it's not quite
two years in but we have literally
spoken to hundreds of witnesses we may
have spoken to even more witnesses than
Muller and we have a very important
story to tell to the American public
okay then you could just tell that story
to the American public instead of just
telling us how important the stories are
gonna tell you know we've seen about
1,000 trailers for this movie at what
points we actually get to see the movie
and then when the Moller investigation
comes out it better be public we need
full transparency cuz all we've seen is
narrative from both sides John Solomon
has a piece over at the hill
specifically talking about all of these
allegations that there were too many
there was too much smoke for the FBI not
to investigate he points out there was a
presidential candidate in 2016
whose husband traveled to Moscow and
collected a five hundred thousand
dollars speaking he fee from Vladimir
Putin cronies while she was still
serving as Secretary of State
negotiating with the Russians there was
a candidate in 2016 who ran a cabinet
agency that authorized the sale of a
large swath of strategic American
uranium assets to Putin who served in an
administration that helped arrange and
approve billions of dollars in nuclear
fuel contracts for Moscow at American
nuclear plants just a short while before
Putin invaded Ukraine whose campaign
Chairman served on the board of a clean
energy company that received thirty five
million bucks from Russia while she was
Secretary of State
whose prominent fundraiser subsequently
came under investigation for possible
illegal lobbying activities involving
Paul Manafort
and Russian back to Ukraine politicians
and whose family charitable Empire
accepted support from a lobbying and
public relations firm working for a
Russian nuclear giant that would be
Hillary Clinton so whenever people say
there's a lot of smoke yeah
welcome to politics where smoke is the
way that this stuff works in a second
we'll get to president Trump's response
to all of these allegations I don't get
to the government shut down as well
first let me remind you that this year
it is your obligation to make your
business better how you can make your
business better well by upgrading your
employees doesn't you fire people means
add some great folks over at zip
recruiter com zip recruit accom slash
daily wire is the best way to hire the
right people unlike other job sites
zipper critter finds qualified
candidates for you it's powerful
matching technology scans thousands of
resumes so identify people with the
right skills education experience it
actively invites them to apply to your
job so you get qualified candidates fast
which is why zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the United
States this rating comes from hiring
sites on trust pilot with over a
thousand reviews right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire if you
love the show show your support for it
and zip recruiter go to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire there's a reason
we use the perimeter here at the daily
wire go check them out zip recruiters
calm slash daily wire they light it
filtered those resumes quickly find the
best employee extraordinarily quickly
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire and again you can try zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that is zip recruiters
comm slash daily wear okay so the
President of the United States has asked
about all of this the FBI investigation
all the rest he's asked about this he
calls into judge Jeanine because this is
our new world where the president has
time on a Saturday night calls since Fox
News shots President Trump calls into
judge Jeanine and he is in she asks him
straight up about the Russian collusion
stuff and here was his response now or
have you ever worked for Russian mr.
president I think it's the most
insulting thing I've ever been asked I
think it's the most insulting article
I've ever had written and if you read
the article you see that they found
absolutely nothing but the the headline
of that article is called the failing
New York Times for a reason they've
gotten me wrong for three years they've
actually gotten me wrong for many years
before that okay so what was funny about
this is you can hear it Trump just
denies it openly right form says listen
this is a ridiculous story the media
people like Maggie Haberman at the New
York Times a reporter who does some good
work okay but she tweeted out Trump does
not deny and as the headline of the
media ran with so judge Jeanine asks him
are you a Russian
and he goes it's the most ridiculous
question I've ever heard it's insulting
and the media I run with well he didn't
deny it did he come on come on you think
that if any Democrat answered that same
question the same way the headline would
have been he didn't deny it
of course he denied it because it's
stupid it's a stupid theory again even
if you think that Trump was in cahoots
with Russia the best available theory
would have been that the guy's a dupe it
wouldn't been that the guy's a pay to
agents of the Russians or involved in
compromise or something and again
there's no evidence for any of this
stuff at this point then the media's
attempt to go after Trump from every
angle is pretty astonishing the
Washington Post has a piece today about
how Trump concealed details of his
face-to-face encounters with Putin from
senior officials in the administration
and members of his own administration
are denying this and folks in Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo as office they say
no we know everything he said to Putin
we know what he said but according to
the Washington Post president Trump has
gone to extraordinary lengths to conceal
details of his conversations with
Russian President Vladimir Putin
including on at least one occasion
taking possession of the notes of his
own interpreter and instructing the
linguist not to discuss what had
transpired with other administration
officials current and former US
officials said Trump did so after a
meeting with Putin in 2017 in Hamburg
that was also attended by then Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson US officials
learned of Trump's actions when a White
House adviser and senior State
Department official sought information
from the interpreter beyond a readout
shared by Tillerson the constraints that
Trump imposed are part of a broader
pattern by the president's of shielding
his communications with Putin from
public scrutiny and preventing even
high-ranking officials in his own
administration from fully knowing what
he is told one of the United States has
main adversaries as a result US
officials said according to the
Washington Post there is no detailed
record even in classified files from
face-to-face interactions with Vladimir
Putin such a gap would be unusual in any
presidency let alone that one that
Russia sought to install through a US
intelligence agencies have described as
an unprecedented campaign of election
interference now I have a possible
alternative explanation as to why
President Trump was seizing the notes of
his interpreters okay here's my theory
my theory is that everything inside this
administration gets leaked and so
President Trump does not want those
notes leaked I mean that really that
that's my theory and that theory
is back to a certain extent by the fact
that not only does everything leak but
if I if I recall correctly there was an
actual article written by an interpreter
in the Trump administration who talked
about how she had who talked about how
she had left the administration right
there was an article in July 19 2018
about the interpreter his call is from
the New York Times and who heard what
Trump said to Putin only one other
American is marina gross the only other
American in the room during president
Trump's meeting on Monday the Vladimir
Putin of Russia was the interpreter for
Laura Bush at the Russian resort of
Sochi in 2008 and interpreted for former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson in
Moscow in 2017 she appears to live in an
apartment in Arlington Virginia is an
employee of the State Department and is
unsurprisingly fluent in Russia but
little else is known about Miss gross
her white pad of notes visible in
photographs from the summit meeting are
probably useless experience government
interpreter said dictated in her
personal shorthand that would be
illegible to anyone else and if she were
to say what exactly transpired should
violate an ethics code of
confidentiality similar to lawyer-client
privilege or the silence of a priest
during confession so they were already
reporting on who the lady was right that
the the media were already targeting who
the translator was right they had full
articles about Marina gross the
translator during the Trump during the
the Trump meeting and then they wonder
why Trump was trying to seize the notes
like the media were trying to take
pictures of her notes
this is wild stuff I mean it really is
amazing so Trump is apparently to blame
Trump is the worst right Trump is to
blame for the fact that he didn't want
his stuff leaking it's I just I find
this I find this to be a kind of absurd
contention by folks that Trump is that
Trump is doing something deeply wrong
again this is all privileged material in
the first place and people inside his
own administration say that they've
heard the conversations do you what do
you think Trump is telling Putin behind
closed doors do you think that he's
actually selling out the democracy do
you have any evidence of that now they
say they're gonna subpoena the
translator fine subpoena the translator
and then you know Trump will do he can
claim executive privilege because that
is executive privilege get the president
talking in front of a translator she
does not get to be subpoenaed by
Congress it's amazing can you imagine
anybody doing this with Obama can't it
like really
I don't like using the can you imagine
the Obama routine but it is literally
impossible to imagine the media going
along with anything like this about
Barack Obama Barack Obama had
back-channel negotiations with the
Iranian government with the Iranian
government actual enemies of the United
States far more so than the Russians I
mean the Russians are enemies of the
United States there's geopolitical phos
would be a better way of putting it the
Iranian czar active enemies of the
United States and Obama was having open
conversations with them
we didn't know any of those details and
everybody assumed that's what the
president gets to do because he's the
president just cuz you don't like the
presidents of the United States doesn't
mean you get to shrink either the
executive power or that you get to
pretend that normal exercise of
executive power is somehow now barred
it's wild so now the Democrats are
claiming that they're going to probe
from some meetings with Putin as though
it was as though he was having these fit
I don't know what kind of spy novels
they're reading honestly pretty amazing
stuff okay meanwhile meanwhile the
continuing the continuing government
shutdown has not ended it moves forward
talk about that in just one second first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and subscribe when you do you
get the rest of this show live you get
the rest of me Andrew Clavin show live
the rest of Michael Noel's show live and
now beginning last week you get two
additional hours per day of the show we
do a live radio show it is available in
150 markets across the United States but
it can't actually listen to it on demand
you can't watch it on demand unless you
want to subscribe are over it's a Lee
Weyer com
so go over there and subscribe right now
what are you doing every day has become
significant three times it's hard for us
so the ask Senya so you ought to
subscribe and make sure that Senya is
well compensated for her efforts go over
there right now and make sure that it
happens daily wire.com $9.99 a month you
get all of those things plus $99 a year
you get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels view it tests her eyes
opponent the leftist cheers hot or cold
tumbler it is indeed magnificent it's
the only thing that's able to get me
through these long days of winter go
check it out right now also we have
Sundays specials coming up that are
going to be just awesome check those out
we have all sorts of goodies for you go
subscribe also subscribe over at youtube
or itunes we really appreciate it we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the government shutdown
continues apace according to a new CNN
poll President Trump is bearing the
brunt of this now I would like to remind
folks that polls a year and a half out
two years out from an election don't
matter at all to the President Barack
Obama's approval rating in the middle of
his first term were not good and then he
won re-election it turns out fairly
easily over Mitt Romney so right now
people all look at Trump's approval
ratings 7 237 percent what a disaster
you know why because there's no opponent
right in a presidential race Trump's
approval ratings even when he was
running against Hillary Clinton never
came close to cracking 50% and then he
won anyway it turns out that most people
see presidential elections as binary in
every election so all the people who are
agonizing over Trump's approval ratings
are so low this is where Trump should
say okay well if I have to take the hit
I take the hit I will give you the
evidence that this is sort of what he
should do so here is the pole the pole
is from CNN Oh defines is that Trump is
being blamed by a majority of Americans
now for the government shutdown Trump's
approval rating in the poll is down to
37% as opposed to 57% disapprove that
disapproval has risen five points since
December which is not a shock since he's
been the subject of unending bad media
coverage and also because the president
can't keep his fingers away from the
Twitter buttons and the the increase in
disapproval for the president comes
primarily among whites without college
degrees 45 percent of whom approve and
47% disapprove which that's a really
interesting stat because what that
suggests is again this has more to do
with media coverage than policy if you
think that whites without college
degrees are really Pro illegal
immigration I'm gonna need the evidence
for that in December his approval rating
with whites who have not received
four-year college degrees stood at 54%
so he has dropped pretty precipitously
among people who don't have a college
degree among whites who do hold college
degrees
Trump's ratings are largely unchanged
and they remain sharply negative 64
percent disapprove 32 percent approve
now what the statistics show is that
whites who do not have college degrees
remain in favor of a wall along the
border with Mexico 51 percent in favor
46 percent opposed but they talk to are
blaming President Trump for the
government shutdown again a lot of that
is the media coverage the public say
that 55 percent say that Trump is more
responsible for the shutdown that are
Democrats and
Congress 32% said to blame rest mostly
with the Democrats another 9% say both
are responsible Democrats are more
unified in their blame for Trump
Republicans are kind of not unified at
all rank-and-file Republicans blame
Democrats by 65% but 23% do blame
President Trump for the shutdown now if
Trump can't sell the shutdown to his own
base that's a trump problem that's not
really a shutdown problem that's a trump
problem it's because Trump went on
national TV
and set it all on the shutdown brilliant
strategizing in communications from the
president independents are more apt to
blame from 48 to 34 and are most likely
to say both sides are responsible
because independents are the only people
who apparently have not lost their minds
yeah again if they say both sides are
responsible it means 48% of independents
say that Democrats at least told some
responsibility for all of us now
here's the part of the poll that is
actually more telling and suggests that
Trump should take a little bit of short
term payment in order to reach some
long-term gain more well more than half
Americans are now blaming Trump for the
government shutdown the wall itself has
become more popular there this new poll
said support had increased for the wall
from 34% to 42% the CNN poll had it
going up from 35 percent to 39 percent
in other words Trump's pitch for the
wall is going well his pitch for himself
is not and that should be okay right I
mean he's the president if he doesn't
he's not up for reelection for another
two years so people who are hitting the
panic button and saying well Trump
should therefore sign some sort of deal
right now
which do you think is gonna be more
important come November of 2020 Trump's
approval rating in January of 2019 or
Americans long lasting feelings about a
wall that he has been pushing for for
years my bet is that the issue itself is
going to be more important than the
approval rating over the government
shutdown government shutdowns have no
long lasting poll effects like none
right in Jinja in January of 2013 there
was a government shutdown Republicans
then won a sweeping victory in November
of 2014
no one cares about government shutdowns
five minutes after they're over the only
thing that people care about is the long
lasting impression of Republicans in
2014 most Americans thought Republicans
want to end Obamacare Obamacare was
deeply unpopular and Republicans took
back the House of Representatives and
the Senate they took both of them they
had the House already they took back the
Senate so why exactly
exactly would we think that there's
gonna be any long-lasting impacts from a
government shutdown now all the folks on
the right who are panicking and saying
we need to end the shutdown right now
it's really hurting from really hurting
Trump dudes approval ratings never been
high when he runs he's gonna be running
against someone he's not gonna be
running against the government shut down
the more important statistic here is not
Trump's personal approval rating or who
Americans blame for the shutdown the
shutdown will end everything will go
back to normal people will get paid the
real issue is how people feel about the
wall if you're a political strategist
that's what you care more about and
that's why Lindsey Graham came to
trumpet he said open the government
temporarily and Trump saying no not
going to do that not interested and he
is correct about all of this because
Democrats are being increasingly forced
to deal with the consequences of their
own intransigence and they look bad
doing this I mean there's a piece in the
in the Washington Examiner today all
about all about the Democrats during the
government shutdown according to the
Washington Examiner some 30 Democratic
lawmakers left the government shutdown
behind on Friday on a chartered flight
to Puerto Rico for a winter retreat with
a hundred and nine lobbyists and
corporate executives during which they
plan to see the hit Broadway show
Hamilton and attend three parties
including one with the show's cast is it
just me or I thought that Puerto Rico
was just hit by a hurricane right right
so if they were hit by a hurricane how
much money are the Democrats spending on
this retreat maybe they should donate a
little bit that to the people who are
suffering in Puerto Rico if this is
their thing those defending the
Congressional Hispanic Caucus bold pack
winter retreat in San Juan planned to
meet with key officials to discuss
cleanup after Hurricane Maria at a
roundtable on Saturday but the weekend
is packed with free time for the members
and their families on a trip apparently
some 109 lobbyists and corporate
executives are named in the memo at a
rate of 3.6 lobbyists for every member
and these includes some of the biggest
lobbyists in the country Senator Bob
Menendez who spotted shirtless on the
beach in Puerto Rico talking to some
blonde lady on the beach and she looks
thank God overage so that's good for Bob
Menendez all of this is to suggest that
Democrats and those sort of optics are
not going to play well for it for
Democrats I think the panic button being
hit by Republicans is a little bit
premature at this point okay
it'll meanwhile Republic
kids have been struggling for an answer
with regard to Steve King we talked
about this last week representative
Steve came from Iowa who was quoted by
the New York Times in an interview that
he did not deny saying that there was
nothing wrong with the terms white
nationalism and white supremacy which is
insane and I called for him to be
immediately primary dan maxed out for
his opponents actually in that primary
Kevin McCarthy the Senate the House
Minority Leader he came forward he said
there will be consequences for Steve
King from the Republican caucus on the
other side that they do not take action
when their members say something like
that action will be taken I'm having a
serious conversation with Congressman
Steve King on his future and role in
this Republican Party what does that as
as a leader there is a number of things
you'll see that has taken place but I
will not stand back as a leader of this
party
believing in this nation that all are
created equal that that stands are
continues to stand and have any role
with us okay so this is the exact right
perspective that McCarthy is
articulating right here senator Tim
Scott from South Carolina the the only
black senator in the Republican caucus
he says that he says some in our party
wonder why Republicans are constantly
accused of racism it's because of our
silence when things like this are said
immigration is a perfect example in
which somehow our affection for the rule
of law has become conflated with a
perceived racism against black and brown
people he says King's comments are not
conservative views but separate views
that should be ridiculed at every turn
possible conservative principles mean
equal opportunity for all to succeed
regardless of what you look like or
where you are from
it is maddening to see so many folks who
believe this and have only good
intentions in their hearts tarnished by
these radical perspectives which is why
silence is no longer acceptable and Tim
Scott is right about this the difference
is the members of the Republican caucus
many of them are not being silent about
Steve King whereas when it comes to
bigotry by Democrats the entire caucus
is completely silent about bigotry by
Democrats let me give you an example
Rashida to Labe is one of the new fresh
faces of the Democratic Party I always
say that because you sort of need a
trademark for how often that is used the
media are constantly saying things about
the fresh faces in the Democratic Party
and it's always the same three fresh
faces right it's always Rashida it's
late
Ilhan Omar Alexandria Ocasio Cortes and
they are fresh not because they're the
only new Congress people but because two
of them are Muslim and one of them was a
former bartender and is kind of pretty
right that's that's really why the media
are paying
to these votes well they're gonna pay
attention but not enough to actually
question the bigotry among these actual
members particularly the anti-semitism
of these actual members so Rasheeda
Talib was sworn in to office and and a
few years ago and he or she was I guess
she was sworn in in Detroit and she
invited a guy named Abbas Hamidah and he
gave her a painting of herself in front
of the US Capitol wearing the kefir
around her neck wearing their the kind
of Palestinian she's Palestinian wearing
the Palestinian ceremonial kind of scarf
that you see very often and he tweeted I
was honored to be a congresswoman
Rashida thule the swearing-in ceremony
in Detroit and private dinner afterward
with the entire family friends and
activists across the country
hashtag Palestine hashtag tweet your
thought means hashtag Rasheeda Talib
okay it turns out that Abbas Hamidah is
like an actual terrorist sympathizer
here's what he tweeted out November 19th
2016 Israel does not have a right to
exist the terrorist entity is illegal
and has no basis to exist other than a
delusional Isis like ideology about
Tommy that has also called for an into
fada he's called for solidarity with
Hamas he was at her swearing-in and
attended a private dinner with her
remember that time that Steve King said
something super racist and then most
members of the Republican caucus said
something about it most Republican
commentators most conservative
commentators came out and condemned him
in his strong language is humanly
possible some of us gave money to his
primary opponent member that sounds like
three days ago remember how many
Democrats have been asked about reshoot
it's lame how many they're all asked
about for calling the president a mother
effer how many were asked about the fact
that she's an anti-semite how many were
asked about rich about Ilhan Omar was a
similar record of anti-semitic
statements how many have been asked not
about Alexandra Ocasio Cortez's bizarre
take on domestic policy but about her
association with people like Linda
Sarsour any how many been asked to
defend their comments zero okay which
just goes to show you the when it comes
to who's being held accountable for the
nasty evil comments within their own
caucus the only people ever held
responsible are Republicans and
Republicans I think hold themselves
responsible as senator Tim Scott is
pointing out
and we try to do better the Democrats
don't try to do better not only do they
not - better they then claim that if you
question them about these things that
it's an evidence of some sort of bias
people were complaining that Rasheeda it
was funny AOC Ocasio Cortez was
complaining that the media were
reporting much more on Rasheeda till
aids calling President Trump a mother
effort than they weren't on Steve Kings
white supremacist comments I agree
that's an imbalance that ought be noted
but I'll tell you an imbalance that also
ought to be noted the complete absence
of anyone making no to the fact that
open anti-semites now sit in the
democratic caucus so we'll get endless
coverage about Steve King that coverage
is justified I think but no coverage of
Democrats who have been making nice with
anti-semites and racists from the other
side of the aisle for years like no
coverage at all and the media are cowed
into silence by people like aoc claiming
that they are insufficiently leftist
it's truly incredible like aoc tweeted
against Josh crash our who's a reporter
for a hotline they was she went after
him because she was because I guess
crash our head had pointed out that she
was saying something dumb and she
complained about the reporters and then
he said well the reporters are just
reporting on you and she said well
they're insufficiently racially diverse
and then he said well why are you
calling for a quota among reporters and
she said I'm not calling for a quota
this is a direct quote from AOC I've
never called for strict quotas just
having representation of one of the most
fundamental voting blocks in the
American electorate which is called a
quota and the media cheer her they cheer
her being left means never having to say
you're sorry it means never having to be
asked about the extremists in your own
coalition it means never having to
answer for the disastrously bigoted
views of your own membership it's truly
amazing how the left is allowed to get
away with this by the media and and
themselves I mean they're supposed to be
the the reminders of the morality of
America these are the people who are
supposed to be the reminders of
tolerance and diversity yeah sure I'm
gonna say I'm gonna take advice from
rashida to lay up about racism and
anti-semitism
yeah I'm really gonna listen to
reporters who won't ask for shooter to
let up question up question but are
going to be but I'm gonna be mulling
over Steve King well
Republicans come out of the woodwork to
denounce him truly amazing stuff okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
this week so this weekend I had the
opportunity to see spider-man into the
spider verse it's great okay it's not
just good it's fantastic hey the script
is really clever the voice work is great
more importantly the art of it is just
astonishingly beautiful I mean the art
of it is fantastic
it's its art in a very different way
than like Aquaman Aquaman that the CGI
is great here
spider-man is done differently than
anything else we've ever seen so what's
fascinating is that Sony owns the
animated rights to spider-man but Marvel
meaning Disney owns the live-action
spider-man I will tell you what I am
much more interested in seeing more
animated movies like Spider Man into the
spider verse then the Tom Hollands
spider-man that we've seen in the
Avengers even though I kind of like Tom
Holland and the adventures this this
movies into the spider verse is one of
most beautifully animated films I have
ever seen in my entire life it's an it's
an amazing it's an amazing artistic
accomplishment basically it looks like a
moving comic book if you can't actually
see the trailer we'll show you a little
bit of the trailer right now they they
combine all these different all these
different styles it's great there is
another universe it looks the sounds
like yours
but it's not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my day would come around this
time I know it's complicated
I don't know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man you have
money right I'm not very liquid right
now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher movies really good and it's all
about basically the basic premise is
that there's a portal that opens and all
the spider-man's from the multiverse are
sucked into this one portal now people
who are comic book fans all have their
favorite spider-man I'm still a Peter
Parker fan I know the younger generation
likes Miles Morales I'm fine with Miles
Morales like I think he's fine
this movie makes him a lot more likeable
than he is in the comics and more
interesting than he is in the comics
he's the center of the film the movies
really good Jake Johnson does great
voice work as Peter Parker from a
different multiverse where spider-man's
kind of a loser like he's divorced from
Mary Jane and he's kind of falling apart
as a human it's the movie is is really I
can't speak highly enough of this movie
it's really good you should take your
kids to see it it is it's not
appropriate for kids probably under the
age of maybe seven or eight but for kids
ten their kid could easily see this
movie and it's not scary in any sense
beyond that and again the animation is
just incredible and it's got a bunch of
like John Mulaney comes in for a bit
that's great Nic Cage comes in as
spider-man noir which is my favorite bit
of the film is that one of the
multiverse spider-man is spider-man noir
so he's like from the 1930s and it's Nic
Cage being Nic Cage so that's great
it's like him coming in and being like
I'm spider-man and I punch Nazis it's
it's terrific go see the film if you
haven't yet if it doesn't win the Oscar
for best animation or best art direction
or something then the Oscars are
irrevocable you read the couple e broken
which they are already we already know
that but worth seeing okay time for some
things that I hate
okay so the thing that I hate number one
there's a director named Duncan Jones he
made a movie called moon which I've
recommended on the show before talented
guy he tweeted this out yesterday and I
just find this obnoxious he tweeted out
I have two kids two and a half years and
nine months old respectively
I'll tell you something I never see
anyone admit they're exhausting
frustrating and life's destabilizing
they are rarely fun
sure smiles are great hugs are lovely
but it's hard and not obviously a good
choice in life this is where people feel
compelled to say I wouldn't change it
for the world but you know of course I'd
reconsider it's exhausting it's banal
it's like looking after your dog you
can't house-trained what it is is that
it is and they are mine hopefully they
turn out okay first of all just to go
back to the first part of that tweet
where he says I never hear people talk
about how exhausting and horrifying
children are how frustrating and life
destabilizing there is he like does he
have actual mental problems does he have
eyes or ears this is the number-one
topic among all parents forever is how
your kids drive you up a wall like
literally you can ask folks at the
office how often do I talk about how my
kids are driving me crazy you don't have
to do that what's into the show like
every other day I'm talking about my
kids driving me crazy
it is also true that they are the best
thing that has ever happened to me and
when Duncan Jones says well you don't
have to add that you know they're not a
great they're not a great choice they're
not obviously a good choice in life when
he says you know I might reconsider I
can't imagine how his kids are gonna
feel 10 years from now reading those
tweets when he says I wouldn't change it
for the world of course I'd reconsider
really would you reconsider then maybe
you should not be a parent seriously and
also it's just it's so self-centered if
kids screw up your priorities it's
because your priorities are screwed up
your priority is your kids you know many
times I've had to ditch things that I
want to go to because I got to take care
of my kids or shift my schedule around
because I have to do something with my
kids and then do you know how awesome it
is that I was with my kids as I've said
I've said this a thousand times in
person and on the show there's one of my
things life is all about the highs and
the lows and basically here's how it
works when you're single your high is
like a seven and your low is like a -
unless you're clinically depressed or
something then you get married and your
high is a ten because you have a partner
in life and that partner in life when
you're with them it makes your it makes
life just that much better and your low
is like a zero because when something
bad happens to the person you're with
then it's worse than something bad
happening to you and my wife is sick it
is much worse for me than when I'm sick
and then you have kids and
boundaries on the upper and lower
thresholds disappear completely the best
things that ever happened you in life
will happen with their kids and the
worst things that ever happened to you
in life will happen with your kids
there's nothing better nothing in the
world better than hanging out with my
daughter and teaching her things and
having her say funny things or me being
in the car and partying with the kids in
the back a great video my kids like to
sit in the back of the car that we have
two car seats in the back I've one who's
five and one he'll almost five and a few
weeks here and one who's two and a half
and I turn on Elvis and they're partying
it out in the back and it's blast
nothing is better than that and then
when something terrible happens to your
kid when your kid is throwing up in the
middle of the night and you're cleaning
it up and trying to make them feel
better or when god forbade your kid has
a surgery or something which I've been
through with my daughter when all that
happens that's the worst thing that ever
happened to you in your life is that
something that you would trade away I
don't know would you trade away seeing
the world in color would you trade away
it's like The Wizard of Oz it really is
before and after having kids I don't
even remember not having kids this is
how it works at every stage of life
there's a point where you don't remember
what happened before after you get
married you don't remember what it was
like to be single it's very difficult to
remember what it was like to be single
because now you have someone you are
attached to and then you have kids and
you really don't remember what it was
like not to have kids which is why you
see so many couples struggling with
empty nest syndrome after the kids leave
because your life totally shifts around
that it's like in The Wizard of Oz the
original Wizard of Oz where everything
is in black and white and then the house
lands in Oz and suddenly the door opens
and everything is in color that's what
it's like having kids so maybe you'd
prefer to go back to black and white
maybe it was safer and nicer for you
there guess what that's because there's
something wrong with your eyes it's
because if you if you look at your kids
and you only see the same blacks and
whites you saw before you had kids then
I would suggest that you have some sort
of vision adjustment cuz you got a
problem you got a problem okay other
things that I hate as I've said before
the entire goal of Western civilization
is to protect innocence that that is
what Western civilization is about it is
about it is about curbing the worst
instincts of humanity whether they are
masculine or feminine whether they come
from one group of people or another
group of people Western civilization is
about the idea that everyone can be
civilized to be a good person and all of
that is designed to protect innocent
people we as a society are failing the
history of Western civilization we are
failing it we are failing it because we
no longer care about protecting innocent
people protecting innocence has become
secondary to our own subjective pleasure
and that means that parents taught us
being a parent
abusing their kids this is this this
case is just sickening
it should sicken you to your stomach
we've talked a little bit before about
this 10 year old drag kid okay there's
this another drag kid now so they're
they're a couple of different drag way
kids these drag kids are 10 year old 11
year olds who have been featured in the
media and they are supposed to be the
heroes of our new society right it is it
is heroic to bring your children your
male children to dress up as female
children in a sexualized fashion well on
Monday a ten-year-old Canadian boy named
Nima's Quin Melancon golden was featured
in a troubling Huck magazine piece
highlighting the life of a so called
child drag queen young Nima's whose drag
name is queen lacked Asia does anyone
care about this kid no I mean let me
know like I care about kid more than
this kid's parents do really I think
that is fair to say and how do I know
that because what I'm about to tell you
was shot by photographer Jonathan
Frederic terton for the spread in one of
the shots that did not make the magazine
Nima sinful drag makeup and a black
dress is posing for a photo with the
season 7 winner of RuPaul's Drag Race
violet chachki
in a shocking photo violet is wearing
nothing but a pair of heels in a small
piece of fabric covering his genitals as
seen in this screenshot interviewed in
photographs Queen lactation for hug
magazine about life as a child drag
queen posted certain turn has shot for
mainstream outlets like the BBC adidas
Dazed and Confused the Discovery Channel
that the Huq magazine piece by the way
called me out personally for over
sexualizing drag kids I'm the bad guy
for pointing out that it is a bad thing
to take ten-year-old boys dress them as
girls and then put them in the presence
of naked men pretending to be women I'm
the bad guy name is his mother Jessica
Malan Khan conceded the drag has a
sexual component and is unapologetic
about her young son wearing sexually
suggesting clothing if it makes him feel
beautiful is according to a man to press
the giacomo over a daily wire she said
drag is an adult arena and that's where
people question our judgment so we have
to censor thing he knows there are adult
day aspects of drag that he's not
allowed to apply to his show we would
never try to overtly sexualize our child
but if you wear something that makes him
feel beautiful what right do I have to
stop him wearing that dress because it
might cause people to think things they
shouldn't
thinking it's a circular problem no it
is not a circular problem you're
damaging your child cuz you're a bleep
you're a bad mother you're a terrible
mother
okay Child Protective Services should be
at your house today today it is
disgusting to violate the innocence of a
child like this and then to pretend
you're doing it for the child's own sake
you wouldnt let your kid not eat his
vegetables you wouldnt let your kid
ditch school you wouldn't let your kid
prostitute himself and yet you are
you're acting as his pimp to put him in
a photo like that you were acting as his
pimp this is endangerment of children in
2007 Nemeth appeared on stage with
popular drag queen Bianca Del Rio and a
drag show his mother brought him to the
clip of the two onstage together were in
the drag queen repeatedly used the word
be with the B word and dropped an f-bomb
quickly went viral according to Jessica
drag is how Nima's chooses to express
himself he's just a kid playing yeah but
you know better don't you you know what
this is you know this isn't just a kid
playing you know that there are people
who aren't going to victimize your child
you know that you are victimizing your
child this idea that you're supposed to
substitute this judgment of your
children for your own judgment as an
adult it's one of the aspects of our
civilization that is going completely
awry the idea of being a civilized human
being is that you don't know crap when
you're a kid and then you get older and
you know crap and you try to stop your
kids from having to experience in the
stem garbage that you experienced and we
now have a society where we're supposed
to supplant our own judgment with that
of our children
let the children roam free in a world of
adults some of them our predators this
genius stuff genius stuff this has
nothing to do with the welfare of the
kid this has everything to do with the
subjective self-satisfaction of a
terrible mother I rarely rip parents
like this but this parent deserves every
bit of ripping and I am dead serious
when I say that Child Protective
Services should show up at this person's
house I mean that is horrifying garbage
okay well with that said we'll be back
here tomorrow we'll go break down all
the latest news for you then and we'll
be back here later today so if your
subscriber we have two more hours of
great content coming up later today
be there or be square I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam say whatz Audio
is mixed by mic core Amina hair and
makeup is by Jess while alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19